I'm zero
take me more
Donald Trump's strode on to the stage to
the sound of John Denver
trying to get the room thinking about
country roads not legal paths but he
couldn't resist the glaringly obvious
where is the collusion you know they're
still looking for collusion where is the
collusion finds of collusion we want to
find the collusion in New York his
longtime lawyer Michael Cohen was
delivering a stunning blow the man who
said he'd take a bullet for the
president had a change of heart
pleading guilty to campaign finance
violations and appearing to claim mr.
Trump directed him to make hush payments
to former porn star stormy Daniels but
without actually naming him what he did
was he worked to pay money to silence
two women who had information that he
believed would be detrimental to the
2016 campaign and to the candidate and
the campaign mr. Cohen's lawyer went
further in a statement asking if those
payments were a crime for Michael Cohen
then why wouldn't they be a crime for
Donald Trump it came soon after the
president's former campaign chairman
Paul Manafort was found guilty on eight
charges a tax fraud bank fraud and
failing to disclose foreign bank
accounts mr. Madoff Ford is disappointed
of not getting acquittals all the way
through or a complete hung jury on all
counts he is evaluating all of his
options at this point it is the first
criminal conviction arising from Robert
mullahs Russia investigation but it was
the surprise turn by Donald Trump's
former fixer that could place the
president in legal jeopardy the campaign
finance charges that Michael Cohen pled
guilty to directly involved the campaign
of then candidate Donald Trump and if
the reporting on what Michael Cohen said
in court is accurate Michael Cohen
directly implicated the president in the
commission of those campaign finance
violations
hugely significant from a legal
perspective whatever the White House
does next whatever Republican
strategists think or voters say two
things are indisputable and mr. Trump
won't like either of them two of his
former allies are expected to go to jail
and there is no end in sight yet for the
robert muller investigation
there has been russia fatigue in america
and plenty of skepticism but an
investigation with many gray areas just
delivered a clear day of explosive
developments Cordelia and Sky News
Washington